le corps de lyne jun a été retrouvé le
29 mai 2012 quatre jours après son décès
malgré la dégradation du corps les
analyses faites par la toxicologue
judiciaire caprine la vallée ont révélé
qu'il avait consommé des médicaments
madame lavallée a identifié deux
substances d'abord du théma est pas un
somnifère que l'on obtient sur
ordonnance ainsi que de la définit de la
mine que l'on trouve en vente libre dans
le benadryl ou le gras vol les deux
médicaments sont des dépresseurs a dit
la toxicologue ils ralentissent les
fonctions mentales et physiques prises
ensemble leurs effets s'additionnent et
la personne qui combine ces deux
substances sera davantage affaibli
catherine la valiha aussi analyser une
bouteille de vin saisis dans les ordures
chez man utah où on a trouvé le profil
génétique de la victime la toxicologue a
découvert la présence de temae pam dans
la bouteille impossible cependant de
déterminer la concentration
plus tôt dans la journée l'enquêteur
antonio paradiso a raconté avoir reçu
une télécopie d'un avocat ontario le 1er
juillet 2012 le message donné des
indications pour retrouver une partie du
corps de la victime que les policiers
recherchaient toujours ils ont suivi les
instructions se sont rendus au parc
angrignon où ils ont trouvé dans un
boisé la partie du corps toujours
manquants l'enquêteur paradiso fait
partie de l'équipe du spvm qui s'est
rendu à berlin en juin 2012 pour ramener
le carreau comme agneau tas qui venait
d'être arrêté dans un café internet
après une cavale de quelques jours en
europe is isabel richer radio canada
montréal